question from the pftpm posse account on
twitter do we think that alden smith and
demarcus lawrence should trade contracts
based on aldon's production through
three weeks versus lawrence's since he
got paid obviously it's in jest they
can't trade contracts aldon smith
probably would be interested in doing
that but the reality is aldon smith has
been their best pass rusher alton smith
has been borderline dominant after five
years out of football he should have
been the week three defensive player of
the week for the nfc i will be stunned
if he's not the nfc defensive player of
the month for september that gets
announced thursday morning alton smith
has been tremendous four sacks in the
seahawks game he was always around
russell wilson and you know that shaq
barrett winning the award versus alden
smith shaq barrett was chasing around
back up scrubs in denver alden smith was
chasing around russell wilson and
catching him
yeah absolutely he's got four sacks the
seven quarterback hits this so far this
year he has been their best pass rusher
and they paid demarcus lawrence to be
that guy and hey look he's playing
through a knee injury right now he
didn't practice today we know all that
but since signing that big contract
before 2019 five sacks 16 quarterback
hits no forced fumbles that's not what
you paid him for and he's played a lot
of games he played every game last
season he's played all three games this
season he has not produced enough for
the cowboys they are grateful they have
aldon smith because if they didn't they
would have been blown out in all all
three games and be oh and three right
now
alton smith reminds me of lawrence
taylor when i see him in the two-point
stance he's got the demeanor he's got
the movement of a late career lawrence
taylor not in his prime and it makes me
wonder
what alden smith would have been
if he'd had a prime if he'd played when
he was 24 25 26 27 28 29 30. he just
turned 31 the other day happy birthday
alden smith but those years lost forever
and it's a shame because we may have
missed out on a truly special talent
sharing
yeah we missed that on the prime of his
career but he's looking pretty good now
and has a few more years left and he's
going to get paid if he continues to
play like this and do the right things
off the field he's going to get paid a
lot of money
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports